[Música]
se puede decir de un jefe de estado que
trata a millones de integrantes de
diferentes grupos religiosos en su país
de esta manera antes que todo debe
hacerse de controles mentales
de fondo la libertad que defenderemos la
libertad que también enseñó y
mantendremos en alto el laicismo no
renunciaremos a las caricaturas ni a los
dibujos incluso si otros lo hacen
todos ya nos hemos dado pasos
importantes
y hemos recuperado la democracia
queremos sobre todo los bolivianos
recuperando las escenas
este plebiscito no es el fin es el
comienzo de un camino que juntos todos
deberemos recorrer para acordar una
nueva constitución para ti
[Música]
las fuerzas de defensa nacional fueron
atacadas esta noche mientras vigilaban
el exterior para defender a la nación
las fuerzas que traicionaron a etiopía
atacaron mientras dormían en el
campamento y en la ciudad de méxico
y
creemos que ganaremos las elecciones con
mucha facilidad creemos que habrá muchos
litigios porque tenemos tanta evidencia
tanta prueba que tal vez termine esto en
el tribunal más alto del país veremos
pero creemos que habrá muchos litigios
porque no podemos permitir que nos roben
una elección de esta manera
[Música]
aún no tenemos una declaración final de
victoria pero los números nos muestran
algo claro y convincente vamos a ganar
esta carrera
horrible yo nunca había vivido algo así
[Música]
lloré y lloré abrace a mis hijos uno se
siente potente porque tiene bebés
pequeños
y no sabe lo que va a pasar mi nombre
del estado
les pido perdón a sus familiares y a
ellos ya todos los jóvenes que marcharon
por defender la democracia
lamentablemente por el tremendo dolor
que atraviesa el país y en todo el mundo
el fallecimiento de diego armando
maradona aproximadamente a las 12 horas
[Música]
para todos aquellos que tienen un pensar
en forma de empresario de una empresa un
país sino pensar en forma agresión
social es desarrollado de tabárez se va
a quedar eternamente
ahora que lo he hecho espero que esto
ayude a otras personas a venir y seguir
adelante para hacer lo que yo hice ya
sabes intentar dar el máximo para
deshacernos de este virus terrible
[Música]